how's it going there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here and it is time
for The Last of Us season one episode
four Tara Erickson joining me once again
Tara how is your life I'm here and I am
great I have a short film dropping
tomorrow on my YouTube channel or just
an FYI what is it called it's called
You're you dude well check that out
subscribe to Tara's YouTube channel turn
on the notification Bell so you know
when more shorts and other cool things
are dropping bring that back
well ring the bell and do that for this
channel as well subscribe uh hit that
Bell and leave a like leave a like for
this video if you're enjoying these Last
of Us noobs reactions with me and Tara
like we've said in the past we haven't
played the games we don't know what's
coming so this is a completely blind
experience and we thank you guys for not
spoiling that for being such good sports
about it and as always if you want to
get the full experience with us come and
sync up with your own copy over at
patreon.com therio rejects you can see
everything that doesn't make these
reaction highlights it's a real blast
over there we also have a ton of other
shows and movies with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included and
if you want to get the full-on expert
gamer perspective head on over to Greg
and Andrew's Last of Us reactions show
them some love but for right now
it's time to hop into episode four are
you ready Tara are you psyched for this
I'm psyched for this stoked let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
someone's got to have taken this and
made like a rap out of it by now right
like a like a sick ass beat you know oh
if they haven't they're gonna do it now
I feel like I should go as fungus for
Halloween like but this type of fungus
just the fungus itself not even an
affected person no just the fungus just
the nice pretty yellow fungus who's in
there
you're gonna have to explain yourself to
people all night it's gonna be great
foreign
all the steps
there's always One in the Chamber
yeah I find your aiming eye
I bet everyone has shot at this gas
station location
seems like the kind of place we have to
do this
breaks down over time back in the day we
dropped 10 12 hours on one tank you
could go anywhere so where'd you go
pretty much nowhere oh
ain't that the truth it's a siphon it's
when liquid
travels Against Gravity because pressure
you don't know I know it works
explain siphoning in the comments this
is your fault then
it doesn't matter how much you push the
envelope it'll still be stationary
volume two
oh my God Ellie's the exact person I
want to hang with in the apocalypse you
can't escape will Livingston
open your heart up to Comedy Joel
looks like there's a storm coming oh
good or is it just really cloudy now
this will end with a twister I'm sure of
it does make you all nostalgic
is actually before my time right
right the winner though sure
I love a little Hank Williams got
something else
right on the reading but it has some
interesting pictures
please get rid of it who's your horses I
want to see what all the fuss is about
no he's your tripod why are all these
Pages stuck together uh oh God
pornography
oh
some gold left on the side of the road I
know someone's gonna have a whole
Awakening when they find that
Arby's
good old loves dude good old truck stop
little did Bill and Frank know there was
an Arby's just outside of town
huh
uh
[Music]
this will go well
it's a ravioli is that Chef oh my God is
it it's Chef that is 20 year old Chef
Boyardee ravioli
I actually agree
that is 20 Euro year old product
placement
so can we start a fire I'm freezing now
why am I going to tell you no people so
what are they gonna do Rob us well
they'll have way more in mind than that
oh my oh no Danger's lurking in the
shadows
it smells kind of good
well that would be Frank's then
oh they're still with us God I wonder
what Bill's sleeping bag smells like
it smells like gunpowder
why did the Scarecrow get an award
because he was outstanding in his field
that's huge
Joel got jokes
got jokes
there's no way anyone knows we're here
right
right No One's Gonna find us
God do everyone finding you
the next morning
[Music]
someone should stay up and take watch
the rifles got this
[Music]
you don't like coffee
you're gonna love it kid she's old
enough to know what coffee is she only
drinks espresso
near settlement probably close to
another city up there ain't too many of
them
in Washington
yeah uh what's his name
whose name your brother Tommy why isn't
he with you long story is it longer than
25 hours because I think that's what we
got
strapping outbreak happens he convinces
me to join a group making their way up
to Boston which I did
is where we met Tess
oh
interesting even Tommy meets Marlene
she talks me to joining the fireflies oh
kind of dream yeah fireflies all over
there's way more of a world to have to
save now of course last I heard he quit
the fireflies too so now he's on his own
out there and
I was asking the big questions
for a girl who didn't know what Cheyenne
was
damn dude that's harsh Broski yeah
that's cold you got it pretty early if
you want to grab more sleep I'm not even
tired
[Laughter]
nice cut
it's a good thing you're not having to
read that Thomas guide through like
cities in Boston those are even worse to
have to pronounce my whole syllables
disappear
oh take that ambulance so much more room
yes and resources Yes To Save a Life
what's the catch we can jog right around
this tunnel
take the next ramp
we're back on the road many times oh no
no no oh
um
he's a Highway oh my God
man
[Music]
what
oh no oh God
built on
are we gonna help him evasive maneuvers
oh my god oh wow
oh my God no oh
my God
oh
yeah you're not heard nothing oh my god
get your gun girl oh my God come on
y'all yep yep yep
is there extra gas
if there is use it as a bomb
at all when I say go you crawl to that
wall and you squeeze through and you
don't come out until I say okay oh
God
hey John you stay low you stay quiet
okay got it go really feel the chaos of
this moment
foreign
[Music]
I mean
you were shooting at him Broski I don't
know why you're getting all mad you all
created this situation people are gonna
die in a gun fight
[Music]
oh
Doritos
oh [__] oh [__] oh oh good quick
thinking
Now's the Time come on girl get that gun
out kill him and don't shoot Joel in the
process
dude Oliver tree lay off oh my God yeah
use that knife get get in there girl
come on no no thinking
come on girl no come on no it's too slow
just okay use the force okay
whoa
no no no no it's okay it's okay it's
over we're not fighting anymore
you're good
oh wow oh we
can guys we could be friends I didn't
know
your name
we have a lot to talk about on the next
car trip
oh
sorry I'm sorry please sorry I'm sorry
please please stop please
oh wow
[Music]
oh
I'm okay I'm good what now you go up did
you get a better look hopefully we spot
a clear route out equip knife
Brian
[Music]
oh boy
he was alone
any of those people
Carrie Schreiber haven't seen them
the chance
Henry Burrell
you know where
this has gone too far
now that you're in the cell
before people dying was okay when you
were safe and protected and ratting on
your neighbor's Defender they put a gun
to my head
delivered you
or I never told them anything about your
brother
but Henry did
think that you know that too
oh where is he
I'm your doctor
yeah it was a good scene she looks so
familiar too I'm trying to place her
name I love her she's in so many things
yellow jackets
oh
no
we found a truck
it's a radio
maybe he found someone out there maybe
he called These Guys in
oh boy what if I had a doctor there's no
chance
I'm sorry I had a fake doctor badge
ready for the Apocalypse
[Music]
this is how I'll get by
proved my worth
[Music]
find who did this
find every collaborator
and Kill Them All
[Music]
We the People
run
[Music]
dude I didn't know this was a prequel to
Mad Max
[Music]
holy junk that's with him okay
serious group of all this is a really
tall building like four blocks away yeah
so so that's the one as soon as we don't
hear a truck we move I can't imagine how
they're gonna get out of this
are you all right yeah oh you care come
on
I don't know what it's like
first time that you hurt
someone like that
if you uh
you need to talk you shouldn't have had
to
and I'm sorry
oh it wasn't my first time
our robbery body counts probably huge
over your thumb left hand
squeezes down on the right got it
steady yourself
look at
it what and then the gun goes off
you put it in your pack
shoot your damn ass off
haven't you seen eight mile
foreign
[Music]
what do you got bud
hope this is not the same tall building
they had their eyes on ah I feel like it
is
someone was a DC fan in the Apocalypse
around our Provisions he's [__] close
I can feel it what
just a long day
wow
oh what
I was gonna say is that caving in or is
that like an impact crater whoa
let's just handle what we have to handle
we can deal with this after I don't know
I don't think so
it's gonna be a really cool shot of a
bunch of Zombies come out of the ground
we're counting on it
take a look around first
Billy
it's great to be without me huh
ouch
sick burn Joel you go way up come on and
I'll take a look at the city and find
our way out
I have a feeling
45. yeah this is the same building I
feel like
or or something bad is is being
contained in here
they're just trying to calm us down with
this relaxing music because the [__] is
about to come down yeah what do you talk
about Tara music means comfort
how did you know it was an ambush
I've been on both sides
come on
huh yes
33 floors that's good whoa get up you
lazy ass
please yes 56 years old you little [__]
I love their Rapport together
[Music]
nice
booby trap it hey Joel's seen home alone
I don't want someone sneaking up on us
while we're sleeping you sure you're
gonna
of course I'll hear it that's the damn
point oh no please don't let them get
stuck up after all this
it's gonna be real real hard after 33
flights upstairs
he might not wake up he's gonna
oversleep what did you mean it wasn't
your first time
probably more from shooting so if you
want to keep your hair and you stick to
that knife
the sore spot
did you know diarrhea is hereditary
it runs in your jeans
[Laughter]
I'm driving a new Chevy and you're
feeling something heavy
you're losing a big time
laughs
foreign
[Laughter]
oh God is he sleeping on his right ear
Joe
oh no no no no
[Music]
shh damn it
kid
Oh Henry it's Henry in the in the in Sam
or whatever oh that's right damn oh what
a cliffhanger
why did it end there Melanie lynskey
that's her name
I'm so frustrated I know right oh my
gosh
holy job not ready for that to be over
ah
it's interesting now that TV can can
I don't know I mean like this still airs
on HBO on television I think so like
they can take as much or as little time
as they want you know because like last
week was like over an hour and this is
you know about 45 minutes yeah they can
just pick and choose be an HBO huh I
guess so well yeah I'm in the age of
streaming I feel like it happens more
but probably every channel can like do
that now right I guess I'm always just a
little more surprised when it's like
someone who's actually on a TV Mighty
mint Mighty mint Mighty mint okay here
just real quick because it says Mighty
mint in the credits is I use Mighty mint
but it's a bug killer so I'm like
is there also Mighty mint production
company
they're they're probably the same exact
entity they're just like we got two
passions in this life we got pesticide
and we have quality entertainment I
would extra support my Mighty Med bug
killer if they were actually helping to
produce HBO shows I'd be like buy me 15
Gallons please because now you know
exactly what money is going and that's
yeah that's what you want really right
that's what you really
oh goodness
[Music]
yeah wow I was gonna ask what you
thought of the episode but what happened
there
I just am feeling the the
you got to a point at the very end of
this episode where they're laughing and
it's such a sweet moment and they've
bonded a lot and it was like a finally a
minute where they had a little bit of
respite and the flip on it is not that
it's an adult is that it's a child going
to kill them
and they're like how do we how do we fix
this yes
that's where that comes from where I'm
like how are they gonna I mean it's
probably just gonna cut two and they're
like playing games or something and
being like yes the next episode will
just be them doing now
they just set up a playroom they never
leave
surrounded by glass on the 33rd floor
this is great it was literally just them
to the most of the entire time except
introducing Melanie right yeah yeah
which we're gonna have to I have a
feeling we're gonna have to learn that
character's name
is it like Rachel or something I can't I
don't I can't remember you can correct
us down below but yeah I mean you know
Melanie lynskey yeah I mean I've seen
her in a bunch of stuff and I mean she's
terrific actors and I mean you know if
even for What Little you know this show
is good at just kind of introducing
characters to you gradually without
having to do major Exposition dumps so
yeah just like getting the feel for who
her character is and what is driving her
you know is very interesting you know
just like a new character to get to know
and especially after
you know last week going headlong into
stories of a different set of characters
you know to sort of flesh out the
greater scope of the world and the story
at hand you know this this is setting me
up to kind of at least expect that okay
like periodically uh
you know it's like last week was a
one-off episode but I feel like this
will continue for an episode or two and
I feel like periodically we will meet
new guest stars in these like isolated
Couple Episode arcs or something like
that but uh I really liked the the haves
of this you know you spend the first
part on the road and you're continuing
to just sort of break the walls slowly
down between Joel and Ellie and yeah it
does nicely I feel like to
play like an actual video game somebody
pointed out uh in uh
I think it might have been it was either
the second or third episode when Ellie
goes down into the uh you know little
space under the floor and she finds the
uh infected in the pile of bricks and
she cuts his face open uh you know we
were like why would you go down there
and people in the comments were like oh
you know like in a video game you
explore all the areas and that's where
like you go to find items and I was like
oh that's that's kind of clever like
using those kinds of activities you
might be doing in a game and then
presenting them here is just
I don't know it doesn't sound as sort of
uh it doesn't sound as big of a deal
when you articulate it but at the same
time I think it is kind of neat that you
can see how certain elements could be a
task that might be you know one of the
things you got to check off in the
progress of the game or whatever right
um so yeah just I don't know watching
them travel and then you know the whole
sort of growth with the gun or the
little thing with the pun book uh and
then siphoning the gas siphoning the gas
and then yeah rolling into a city and
getting that sort of classic like okay
someone's asking for help but it's
secretly an ambush and now you know
we're gonna be into the next sort of
intense part of the story for right now
like it seems like they are
it doesn't seem like the show where they
need to have like here's a there's a big
action set piece there's a big infection
set like we don't really even see
infected much in this episode no not at
all yeah right yeah not at all and yet
it's still like super tense and ominous
and and observing you know
I think you're gonna find out fungus
around every corner but
there wasn't any I know just like blood
and dead people maybe people are going
to be just as mad as they were last week
yeah but there was no infected I can
just tell that the the response to this
episode will be one to one the same
well it's a TV show okay you gotta like
the characters too the real why both the
real stuff that's not what shows are
about the real Jews it's not what shows
are about you know it's about the
literal beats of the plot and nothing
else Tara it's all I care about that's
my infected for those people who are mad
that there was no infected
I like it twice there dude you're
welcome see you got the infected quote
it was weird for the week it was
different yeah right I love the the
sound effects yeah this is good I moved
my arms like weird too I mean I added a
whole thing he can rewind and slow-mo if
he wants yeah yeah I'm gonna do that I'm
just gonna make the rest of this review
just a loop of YouTube
but yeah yeah cresting into the the sort
of new area this quarantine Zone that
appears to be like abandoned or whatever
and then yeah it turns out that there is
a settlement but even they are sort of
off in their own sort of sub-sective
the remnants of the world and and you
know I'm a curious
to see how much we'll learn about that
because I feel like part of what the
show is doing is
you know it focuses in on things and it
examines you know human moments and
little granular aspects of of life
especially you know as contrasted by
this apocalypse scape but it also seems
like it is willing to keep you somewhat
in the perspective like in this episode
your shifting perspectives but I feel
like you know we might not get the full
fleshing out of whoever this group is
before we move on necessarily and that
sort of feels like it might in life you
know you learn kind of a fragment but
you're on your own Journey they got to
get out of here as soon as possible
which is going to be hard but at the
same time yeah I just wonder how much
fleshing that's gonna get and how
they're gonna realize that because right
now it's very intriguing and I like that
they do yeah they they set it up so you
know who the antagonists are to Joel and
Ellie but they're also building up you
know this other couple people that
they're looking for and the unrest
within their camp and then I thought
that made for a great reveal at the end
yeah I'm wondering if it's going to be
like a cult and those two people they
were like we're out of this cult we
don't believe in it anymore you guys are
nuts and then they went and they left
and they drew some pictures upstairs and
now they found they found you know yeah
found Ally I don't know I don't know
what's gonna happen they're gonna be
like listen we can't go downstairs
because it's a cult down there
maybe they just like jump out the window
Because he believes in Superman that's
oh no I can fix it yeah and the kid just
yeah that would be bad yeah
you know that's the kind of show this is
we might have a cult waiting for us some
cult stuff yeah the fact that they were
like we're not going to tell these
people about the ground moving up and
down and the people are down below I
think I guess yeah there yeah there must
be I don't know if they maybe took their
infected and like hoarded them off
underground I feel like there are
certain things that in shows like this
or stories like this you can sort of
count on at some point like yeah maybe
there's a grouper like we didn't want to
kill them all so we just contained them
all or something like there's a Walking
Dead plot line like that and I'm sure
there are other uh infection outbreak
zombie plot lines that sort of mirror
that but I I am curious because we don't
quite know what it is and you know
that's going to come back and that's
going to be something fun uh I hope it's
a giant fungus that's like it's so big
it's grown and now it's just it's the
top it's the butter lettuce on the top
of just like a huge I don't know can
they get bigger no maybe I don't know
maybe it's multiple big old reishi
multiple zombies and their fungus has
been like you know fused together like a
king rat or something so it's an extra
large King uh butter lettuce head trying
to get through the asphalt and try to
get through that asphalt yeah tell you
right now
that's that's cool
and if it's not that I'm gonna be very
upset now that you've set my
expectations yeah well that's what I do
but yeah I like the the growth the
progression of this and I thought the
way they handled the whole Ambush thing
was really nice because
you know in that moment where the dude's
like you know freaking out and begging
for his lights like it becomes a very
sad moment and it becomes this weird mix
of yeah like Ellie saves Joel's ass but
also
I like the way they chose the details
like she must have shot him in the low
back because he's like my legs don't
work and then you're you have this whole
like series of conflicting emotions
because you're like well yeah I mean you
know it's a little late to just be like
I'm sorry guys like please cut me some
slack I didn't know I'm like you didn't
have to lead with ambushing us and and
you know trying to kill us necessarily
but uh yeah I liked the sort of sad
bitter sweetness of that and then you
bring them back to the rest of the
people and I like that they didn't
immediately go like it's definitely
those you know Raiders or whatever who
killed him yeah she kind of thought that
he that they were like maybe Henry sent
them yeah yeah yeah or maybe this is
part of the bigger situation so it's
like they're not necessarily in that
moment it feels more like their priority
is still whoever this Henry guy is and
even though you know that you know Joel
and Ellie are in trouble and and part of
their goal is gonna be to neutralize
them too you know it doesn't seem like
they are the number one priority which
is just like again an interesting little
Dynamic and I think it's a nice
sort of nuance I suppose because yeah
they do have such a focus on something
that is much more you know at home to
them
uh yeah but next episode it's gonna be
all fungus I feel it all infected all
fungus I feel like yeah and that's going
to be a huge problemo
but it's gonna be cool yeah because then
they're all gonna have to fight together
because it's going to be like listen we
don't know who we hate anymore we just
have to like not get infected we just
gotta yeah not we gotta all not eat it
and bring the collapse of this pocket of
civilization too maybe we'll let you
just go yeah or something I don't know
like yeah I'm I'm excited to find out
because the Father and Son sets you up
for one idea of uh because I think it
was I think it was two of them it was
the kid and and probably his dad and
yeah so in this moment to end the
episode off you're like oh [__] you know
the the the the the town the people have
found them Melanie lynskey's people have
found them oh wait no so in that moment
you have that brief sigh of relief but
I'm also like I don't know man like in
in shows like this and stories like this
oftentimes you know you think you find
somebody who's gonna be you like a help
only to discover that they are further
warped by the reality that they now
inhabit so like I said cult
that's right man or or yeah or they
could be the only sane people yeah the
whole bit with with the doctor like just
yeah just like I think they do really
nicely whether it's a deep dive like
last week into a couple specific
characters or if it's just you know
giving bits of life to you know new
characters that we're meeting as a group
I think they do nicely with all those
things
and uh yeah great chemistry building
between Joel and Ellie over time yeah
and I feel like Ellie is going to cut
the tension with the kid
because she's got jokes she's got jokes
she's gonna say a joke she's gonna ask
him a question he's a kid he's gonna
answer she's gonna make him laugh
and then maybe Joel will be able to grab
the gun dude there you go and then this
kid will introduce her to Superman comic
books yes yes add us to the writer's
room that's right don't put me in that
room just put me in the show just put
you should be cast in the show hey
season two is already Greenly get that
put staple some butter lettuce to your
face and get that self tape going
well all right any stray thoughts before
we get out of here I don't think so the
good ass episode I'm excited to see how
how this situation spirals further out
of control uh when also curious when
Uncle Tommy is gonna actually reappear
if and how uh because yeah we talked a
lot about him this week yeah and uh and
Ellie learned what a gentleman's
magazine is and apparently magazine is
yeah and a coffee too
you'll get it someday she's living she's
learning someday so are we John yeah
well guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe hit the notification Bell
leave a like on the video and last not
least well shout out shout out
Garth McMurray you are our newest Patron
to be shouted out last month so you're
kicking off the month this month partly
because just looking at your lovely
profile pic over here you you look like
someone who would thrive in this
universe you know you got the beard but
you also got a little bit of that gray
in there you know so we know you've been
through some [__] man yeah you know but
also you got kind of a little bit of
that Nick Offerman like oh man maybe
this guy will beat my ass but also maybe
this guy's gonna be a sweetie like you
know maybe he's gonna make me laugh and
and serve me Beaujolais cool so sign me
up mcmur Beaujolais McMurray that's your
new nickname
but yeah dude hope you're doing well
hope this is a show up your alley uh you
know leave us some comments and uh and
you know fill us in about your life and
times so that the next time we can just
read your whole life story out yeah I
would do that I would do it like in like
an in an in an accent you know if you
want to if I if I'm here what kind of
accent like you know I've got
um
um your Patron for 22 days pretty good
right or sick y'all better pledge twenty
dollars here that one is also great
um
Uh Oh Long Island like uh uh lifetime
supporter they're a lifetime supporter
so they've you give like the forty
dollars see that one's also good or like
Gareth McMurray
yeah
it was both see I don't know I don't I
don't know what any of mine were either
it's okay John you you favor girls if
you can tell us then you know that would
be great that's your job now just break
it down tell us all the accents we just
did
this has been your shout out I hope you
enjoyed it this is one of the more
off-road ones that's what we do here
Garth all right so be well and we'll
catch you on the next one love you bud
[Music]